[Music]
[Applause]
e
[Music]
h
m
[Music]
oh
for
[Music]
m
sh
[Music]
oh
true
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
m
[Music]
SC
oh
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
for
n
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
sh I
I
[Music]
oh
e
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
is e
oh
[Music]
the
d
[Music]
oh
around e
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
you
a
[Music]
for
all
[Music]
what
for
[Music]
that
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
that
[Music]
is
what e
[Music]
true e
e
[Music]
hello hello hi everyone thank you so
much for joining us for um another
session this morning uh welcome to
everyone who's just come in I'm really
excited to introduce you to the next
speaker just one little reminder when
the speaker comes on there's going to be
a QR code on the right hand side of the
screen we would love to hear the
questions that you have just to make it
like more interactive so feel free
throughout the entire talk to just put
in your questions onto the system and
we'll be able to um answer some of them
after the talk is over so a quick
introduction I'm Deborah I'm from Yap
Global and I'll be your MC for this
morning so let's get right into the
session the topic of discussion today is
the hunt for impactful use cases from
the crypto for good fund and
specifically what 15 blockchain Pilots
revealed in Emerging Markets so to
present this is Timothy aimo let's
welcome him on
[Music]
stage good morning
everyone my name is Timothy and I'm from
Uganda and I work with maso Ventures
which is the impact investing arm of
maso which is a global
nonprofit um operating in more than 40
countries across the
world um and today I'm here to share
more about um what we've learned from
running more than 15 Pilots across imaji
markets um so I lead the crypto Venture
Lab at maso ventures and I'll just give
you a quick intro of maso Ventures um so
we like I said we are the impact
investing arm of maso and to date we've
supported over 50 startups um that have
gone on to raise over $500
million um and our thesis is centered
around increasing the financial
resilience and climate resilience of
people in Emerging
Markets um so in terms of what I hope to
cover today one is about the crypto for
good fund um which is an initiative by
maso Ventures and two is an overview of
what we've seen in the web 3 ecosystem
in imagin markets and then three I hope
to provide you um three deep Dives on a
few Pilots that we've run um as part of
the crypto for good
fund so I guess quickly um about the
crypto for good fund um I guess a good
place to start is the context that led
us to to to to launch the crypto for a
good fund and there's two important
things to note um you know web 3 hype
hasn't matched reality um there's always
been you know everyone is aware of the
promise of blockchains but as we stand
here today much of that hasn't been felt
especially in Mari markets um we still
have billions of people who are
financially excluded um over 1.7 billion
adult and nearly 60% of these happen to
be women um and at the same time um you
know climate vulnerability is is a real
thing and we have over 120 million
people at risk of falling into poverty
um because of the effects of IM of
climate change which are being felt the
most in imaging markets um so it's sort
of these these um realities are sort of
what led us to launch the crypto for
good fund and with a crypto for good
fund our aim is to close the hype Gap in
web 3 um and we basically do this in two
ways um so one is we partner with
different startups to launch Pilots that
are testing out real world use cases of
web 3 and two is we share all the
findings that come out of these Pilots
publicly um you can access all the
reports on on our website which have all
the key learnings and insights that come
out of these
Pilots um yeah and then a quick overview
of where we are today um we've launched
over 15 Pilots to date um and these
Pilots are running across 10 countries
in Africa Latin America um as well as
South
Asia
and um cumulatively our Pilots have
reached a total of more than 40,000
participants and we've deployed over $2
million across these
Pilots um so just want to quickly share
with you a few of the learnings that
we've seen um coming from reviewing you
know so many different applications and
and also seeing the pilots that have
been running um as part of a crypto for
good fund um so we've we've we've had
over three rounds of the crypto for good
fund so far and we've received more than
500 applications and across this pool a
a few patterns have emerged one is that
the web3 space is still nent in Emerging
Markets about um only 30% of the
startups applying for the crypto for
good fund have actually completed a
formal fundraising round so many of
these companies are at the precede stage
and then the second interesting um
promising finding is that many of these
startups are actually targeting Builders
um actually targeting user groups which
are underserved and um from our from our
statistics we see that the most popular
segments are small holder Farmers
lowincome people as well as
msmes um so now I'd like to provide a
quick overview of some of the high
impact Pilots that we've seen out of the
crypto for good fund and provide you a
deep dive on three of these
Pilots um so these are a few of the
pilots that we've run and as you can see
they span a variety of sectors and
geographies um and they have a wide
range of user groups all the way from
low-income users to small holder Farmers
um for instance we run a pilot to
provide um smart contract weather
insurance for 12,000 farmers in Kenya
and this was in partnership with EA
Africa and E risk and we'll do a deep
dive on this shortly we run a pilot in
Cameroon which tested the use of
tokenization and fractionalization of
government bonds to make savings more
accessible to low income users um
another example I'll highlight from this
least is the pilot that we run to
provide anticipatory cash transfers to
pasture lists in Kenya and we'll dive
into this shortly as well um and then we
also run a piloting that leveraged nft
sales to Source liquidity to provide
affordable climate housing to more than
30 families in mamb um so these are some
of the examples of you know web 3 in the
real world um that we've seen as part of
a crypto for good fund and you know if
you're curious to learn more I'll invite
you to visit our website where you can
read more about the pilots about the
hypothesis we're looking to test and the
key learnings that came out of these um
yeah but for now I'll provide a quick
Deep dive on a few of these
Pilots um
the first one I'll start with is a pilot
that we run in Cameroon um and we did
this pilot in partnership with a startup
called iara iara is a financial
technology app which is designed for
users in frankophone Africa offering a
range of investment and savings services
including the ability to purchase a
variety of
cryptocurrencies um so for many of the
users that are using this app it's more
like a crypto exchange um and this pilot
um reached over 11,000
users um i' would like to provide a
quick overview of um the context in
Cameroon just to give you an idea of the
market need um so in many African
countries
um um government bondes are probably the
best savings product with regards to
high yield low risk um but the minimum
amount to purchase a Government Bond is
about $1,500
this is Out Of Reach for many lwi income
people and so the idea of this pilot was
to take um the idea of tokenization and
fractionalization of government bonds
you bring these Bonds on chain and
you're able to fractionalize them and
then people can access this product for
as little as $1.5 us so aara was able to
cut down the cost um to cut down the
cost to the minimum amount to purchase a
Government Bond by 1
000x and you know that was the key
hypothesis of this pilot um I'll quickly
share bit um about the key findings that
came out of this pilot um so one the
pilot enabled access to a high yield low
risk savings product for many who didn't
have prior access so out of the users
surveyed
46% um of the pirot participants say
that they hadn't been able to access
such a product before
um so that sort of gives you a sense of
you know the power of lowering costs and
how that impacts Financial inclusion and
then the second key finding from this
pilot was that it actually helped to
improve the financial discipline
planning and overall servings experience
for users who saved more than once on
the app um so more than 2/3 about
66% um of the surveyed users reported
that um you know they saw improvements
in their financial discipline and
planning and um on this slide you can
see a quote from one of the pilot
participants um you know mentioning
how this is giving them access to a
service that previously they couldn't
access and this is helping them build
Financial
Independence um another pilot that I
would like to highlight um from the
crypto for good fund is one that we run
in Kenya um and I guess um um a little
context about the the cont um the market
need here um so we have over 50 million
pastur lists in subsaharan Africa and
they basically rely on you know
pastoralism um for their livelihoods um
but you know the effects of climate
change are threatening their way of life
um we've seen more prolonged droughts
more recently in the Eastern Horn of
Africa and at the same time um today 99%
of humanitarian Aid is delivered
reactively that means it's delivered
after the disaster happens after the
worst effects have been felt um however
research shows that um many of the
humanitarian crisises in the world more
than 50% are actually somewhat
predictable and so um bringing these two
ideas together the hypothesis of this
pilot was
um you know can we use onchain remote
sensing together with smart contracts to
increase the speed of delivery and
reduce the costs of humanitarian Aid um
and so yeah permitting um the product
using smart contracts the pilot reduced
the payout Times by
97% um for money industry average of
about 45 days to just 24 hours um and
then the second key finding we saw was
that um smart contract
automation enabled an increase in the
coverage amount so EA Africa actually
reassigned three Actuarial staff to
other roles within the company which
helped them save costs and this and they
basically passed this on to their
customers by increasing the coverage
amount of of the policies um and you can
see one of the quotes from a pilot
participant um you know highlighting the
impact of this pilot he says I now have
less stress about how the weather will
affect my produce each season because I
know the company has me covered um so
this sort of gives you a sense of um
these were just a few examples of some
of the pilots that we've run um in
imaging markets and you know the idea
was to sort of highlight some of the
real world web through use cases that
we've seen in Emerging Markets um yeah
and so with that you know happy to open
it up for questions um I'll just mention
that the crypto for good fund the fourth
iteration of the fund is now live and
you know we're receiving applications up
until December 20th and we provide
grants to startups that are building um
that are building web through Solutions
in imaging markets um we provide up to
100,000 to each startup and so if you're
interested you know i' would encourage
you to to scan this QR code um to apply
yeah we that happy to take any
questions thank you so much
Timothy uh two QR codes on screen great
awesome uh thank you so much for that
amazing talk uh the QR code is on screen
here please uh take a photo of it so
that you can ask some questions
basically once you get to the screen you
just need to scroll all the way to the
bottom right and there's a live Q&A
button for you and you can submit some
questions so let's go ahead and get
started here the first question Timothy
says you mentioned web3 hyp has not
matched reality uh making money as I
think all of us know is a big incentive
in the space do you have any ideas on
what can incentivize better
participation um yeah so that's that's
definitely right um yeah you know a lot
of a lot of crypto Space is really about
you know graph go up and so um I think
one of the things we've seen that
actually incentivizes um people to come
into this space is some of the success
stories that we see right um so for
instance when you prove that crypto
actually is able to lower the costs is
able to lower the barriers to access
um and you know even someone who wants
to make profit understands that by being
able to broaden the user base then you
know you're able to build a much bigger
business so I think from our perspective
you know the way um the way that we sort
of encourage more profit-seeking people
to take an interest in this space is
just showing them you know the scale
that's available to tap in there's so
many people who don't have access to
servings products you know there's so
much the billions of dollarss of funds
in humanitarian Aid that are moving
across the world and so if you're able
to make that process more efficient you
know reduce it from 20% to 5% you can
make a mark up of 2% which is a decent
amount of money so that's you know that
would be my perspective on on that
question thank you so much so we'll move
on to the next question do you have
insights on what it takes for a
promising pilot to make systemic change
right um yeah so you know obviously um
creating systemic changes is a
multi-year process um but I think you
know what we've seen is it's sort of
baby little steps that sort of um in the
grand scheme of things tend to make a a
sizable impact so for instance um the
pilot that we run with aara in C in
Cameroon was tokenizing government bonds
and you know like you might have had in
many African markets um The Regulators
either don't really get crypto or in
some markets they're actually hostile to
crypto but what we saw happening in in
Cameroon was that um aara was getting
government bonds and putting them on
chain and then the government realized
that you know wait a minute this this
could actually help us sell more bonds
and so the central bank is actually Keen
to sort of work with a Jared to um you
know find ways to help them sell more
government bonds um what's interesting
though is that it's not the central bank
is not the one that regulates um you
know the crypto space but I guess it's
sort of like it it gives them a way into
you know to influence government
officials if you have a few people who
actually see the benefits um that this
solution can provide then that sort of
gives you a bit of buying when you're
going to talk to um to other regulators
and so you know from my perspective I
think that's sort of one of the ways um
that that you can see systemic change I
think um another way is is just around
um lowering costs so for instance we've
you know one of the use cases that has
been proven at this point is the use of
stoc coins to lower um transaction fees
across borders um and you know
systemically what what what this enables
is all of a sudden you know an African
Merchant can purchase products you know
from A supplier abroad and you know
because of the lower fees then
um they have more they have more working
capital so if if it's going to if you're
going to reduce the delivery time by
just a few days all of a sudden you know
those few
days um those 3 days actually translate
into a significant increase in their
working capital which allows them to
scale their business even more
um yeah that would be my perspective on
on that question great thank you the
next one up is what have been some of
the challenges you've had to overcome to
operationalize these
Pilots yeah so I think you know one of
the obvious challenges given the
demographic um for many of these Pilots
who're working with more holder Farmers
lwi income populations and so um
naturally you know when it comes to
things like smartphone adoption they're
probably going to have a low smartphone
adoption rate than people in urban areas
and so for many of these Pilots you know
we had to um either you know work around
that um have you know in some instances
you could have someone in a community
that has a wallet that is sort of
receiving funds on behalf of users in
some instances in some markets you know
um some startups have come up with ussd
based wallets um so these are able to
work on feature phones um yeah but by
and large you know there's also a huge
component of user education um you know
many people have no idea about how web
through Works um and so you know one key
component across any pilot is you have
to spend a couple of days just um you
know training people about the benefits
um in some instances you know the the
crypto is running in the background and
you know you don't have to talk much
about the technical stuff and you just
have to to tell them about the actual
benefits to their lives
um yeah but I would say you know by and
large the the the key challenge is
always around um what devices do the
pilot participants have and how are you
going to walk around that and make the
pilot
successful great we're moving on to our
next question we've got a couple minutes
left you mentioned many Finance focused
use cases what are your thoughts on
deepin use cases such as cellular
networks right um
yeah so that's right um I think we've
seen a few DP news cases um as as part
of our
applications I think you know the
challenge with dpin is always you know
how do you Kickstart the network um and
how do you get you know a few people to
buy in and and sort of be like the um
the Pioneers um to to stand up DP
Network um but I guess one one example
I'll highlight which is a pilot that we
actually have launching soon is with a
startup called Liquid Star um and
they've sort of figured out a way to um
to design um Micro Data Centers
operating within a ship the size of a
shipping container and these are powered
by solar and you know they're also using
Starling for internet um the price point
is still still a bit high but I think
it's one promising use case that we've
seen um and yeah you know I think the
key challenge deep in is how do you
bring down the you know the entry the
entry cost down um to to a point where
it's easily accessible by a wide range
of people and at the same time it makes
um it makes business sense for someone
to be part of the
network we've got just over a minute
left what defi savings products have you
seen being used if
any what defi savings products have have
you seen
yeah um not sure if I fully understand
that but you know um the what we saw
with a Java pilot was um you know by
tokenizing the government bonds then um
they were able to offer this as a
savings product um to their users
enabling them access to a high yield
lowrisk product that they previously
didn't have access to so that's one
example of a defi savings product great
and one last question um are specific
challenges that Builders are facing
Builders have come to you to talk about
these challenges maybe when they're
creating solutions for some of these use
cases um yeah you know what like I
mentioned you know one one challenge is
around devices and wallets um I think
you know obviously I can't fail to
mention the regulatory challenges in
many African markets you have um
startups that's operating in a legal
gray area so many of them find that they
have to incorporate their startup you
know in some other country um but then
they're operating locally um and also
you know sometimes it's also hard just
to pit to investors and sort of convince
them um to overcome that regulatory risk
when it comes to
fundraising great so that was the last
question thank you so much can we give
Timothy a round of applause
thank you all for being a great audience
thank you for submitting all those
questions um we are going to start with
our next session very soon it's going to
be our first panel on this stage this
morning the panel is called building a
better community in Africa from ground
up the hurdles to navigate The Silo
mindset and overcoming overcoming it
with clear conviction so don't go
anywhere um we're going to start
actually in just 3 minutes so I'm going
to see you then
[Music]
a
for
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
for
[Applause]
[Music]
m
is
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
see
oh
[Music]
is
a e
[Music]
it's
is
[Music]
oh
in
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
the
for
[Music]
e e
for for
[Music]
that
you
[Music]
e
I o
[Music]
all
oh
[Music]
e
n
[Music]
your o
for
[Music]
oh oh
m
[Music]
h
oh
[Music]
here right
I
[Music]
for
is
[Music]
GM
GM technically good afternoon but good
morning uh thank you so much for being
here on the last day of Devcon we've had
an amazing week I'm sure you have as
well um I am super excited to invite
invite the panelists on stage but before
that um if you guys are standing uh
please I encourage you to come and sit
or if you're having conversations feel
free to do so outside um can I get the
crew at the back to come all the way in
front would love to see some Malaysian
support right up at the front come over
and support the ogs on
stage thank you so much so um we're
going to have the opportunity to ask the
panelist some questions uh when they
come on there's going to be a QR code on
the right hand side and you can take a
snap of the QR code all you have to do
is just scroll right to the bottom on
the right hand side is a link to check
out the Q&A so you can put in all your
questions and we will have 10 minutes at
the end of the panel to go over some
questions um a very quick introduction
I'm Deborah I'm from Yap Global I am
from Southeast Asia from Malaysia uh so
happy to see all all the ogs in Malaysia
I think Vietnam Singapore also coming on
stage so without further Ado I'm going
to introduce the panel we're discussing
debunking myths about building out in
building out of Southeast Asia and I'd
love to introduce um all the panelists
on stage we've got harith kamaro uh ly
Lou Matthew tan and Tian Lee let's
welcome them on stage
[Music]
all right good afternoon
everybody uh can I get a show of hands
how many people here are not from
Southeast
Asia all right and the rest of you are
all uh
locals thanks for the support um so we
have uh TN Matthew and L um before we
start talking about building out of s
Asia I think it's important for people
to understand your stories uh for this
space so if you mind giving a quick
introduction about how you got into this
space and more importantly where you
were in your life like geographically
career-wise like where were you in that
phase of life so we can start with
ti yeah hi I'm Tien um CEO co-founder of
Pendle I got
started in crypto
um as a hobbyist back in 2014
when I was doing a research for a
professor
on fintech um at the point in time I
think like fintech was still very
heavily tied to
sorry the entire crypto sector was very
heavily tied to fintech um and yeah just
looking
through
um various business models and ideas and
I thought like Bitcoin was was um very
interesting um
was involved in the space as Volunteers
in couple of projects but I became
professionally involved in crypto more
seriously uh when I joined kyber in 2017
so yeah ly here former boss um but it
was it was a fantastic opportunity
because it opened a lot of doors um I
got to see the evolution of Def crypto
as a whole at the front row seat um and
I and I would attribute everything that
I know about crypto
today to the experience it all started
from uh the kyber days um yeah I was
I've I've always been in Southeast Asia
travel a lot but um primarily been based
out of Southeast Asia my entire
life and maybe I'll skip Matt just
because uh TI mentioned uh Lori uh like
um for like how was your uh introduction
to the space and then how did you
introduce uh TN as well
um I was a PhD student at National
University of Singapore um very early in
my PhD career I was given the
opportunity to explore whatever that I
want to do with my life uh so that was
the best part about n us um yeah so I
stumbl on a couple of like articles
about Bitcoin and um I was like okay
this sounds interesting um I decided
like to
basically you know dive a little bit
further into it um and I think a few
months after that like the white people
of ethereum was introduced and everyone
was like talking about uh ethereum
everywhere right and basically it opens
like a lot more opportunities for people
to do stuff on top of ethereum Cu I
think back then like I think Bitcoin was
I think at the stage in which like
anything that you want to do is going to
cost like you know a lot of cussion and
it's like it's going to take like years
in order to do anything and when etherum
was introduced it's like the fresh new
energy into the cryptocurrency space um
so basically my whole uh uh PhD thesis
was all about like scaling public
blockchain like ethereum making smart
contract smarter uh more secure right um
so we I actually wrote uh one of the
first open source uh uh smart contract
security scanner um it was around the
time of the he in 2015 um got the
opportunity to talk and meet uh a lot of
RM researcher in the early days
including Vita lake and a few other
people um 2017 um I think yeah I think
2016 2017 cuz like we keep like go there
were only a few meetups like in
Singapore back then right about crypto
and blockchain and that's how I got to
know like a lot of other people like
Tenn and a few other OG people in the
space 2017 when I was about to get out
of my PhD um I decided to work on kaiber
and yeah
um yeah that was how uh it started yeah
and mat so I see a lot of uh friendly
faces um so for those who don't know uh
probably unlike what uh T so I've been I
had already been in the tax base for
close to uh 15 years plus in the
software industry you know with uh and I
know again know being there for 15 years
previously was a long time uh I guess I
was getting uh
Restless uh and I like like both both of
them here I think I heard of uh Bitcoin
in uh
2011 and uh and being U Asian Malaysian
like no this was a it was like a money
printing machine right so you could on
your turn on your PC and you earn $2 and
$3 back then uh so that got me uh really
intrigued and it uh it felt like uh uh
it felt like uh the internet back in 20
in uh 1995 when I was still in uni so um
so yeah so just started going a little
bit deeper into deeper into it uh and uh
build some some stuff on on bitcoin and
obviously when uh ethereum came along it
was very uh intriguing you could
build this like programmable smart
contracts on the blockchain uh yeah and
then since then I think we've been
really focused uh it's a core focus on
on building out the uh data
infrastructure making that data
available for public and uh hopefully
allowing users to use that data to make
uh informed decisions so yeah and so you
know how TN met Loy uh how did mat meet
uh the other two okay oh okay uh so I
think with law I didn't really meet him
was more like online right yeah I'm
sorry I think it was uh during the I C
Matt wanted some allocation he like can
you give me some allocation I was like
okay it SC good yeah cool so not now
that that he mentioning that's it was
like 2018 2017 yeah so I saw law you
know this young PhD student from n us
right uh you know had this brilliant
idea so you know uh in in 2017 it was
just much more easier I think I pinged
him online and said hey La you know uh
let's chance right so that chat led to
one thing another and I think we've been
able to build a very long friendship and
relationships since then uh We've helped
each other in different parts of our
journey when when times were tough uh so
I do appreciate that friendship with uh
ly and and
partnership uh and that's kind of when I
met uh Tenn right so I know this TN was
this still young but younger back then
really aggressive uh V guy going out
there and stuff like that and I think
when we also kind of invested in some of
the early projects that that t end did
so it's a quite a interrelated
relationship yeah and I think we didn't
really cover that much but uh ly how did
you find the end how did you like hire
him to join the KY team I think it was a
very natural kind of decision right I
mean back then uh I was about to uh I
mean I I knew that I could start
something but I didn't really like
finalize what it was and stuff right and
uh I was a p the researcher uh technical
person um I obviously obviously needed
some help right um so I met TN via I
think either like a referal like some
introduction or like some Meetup cuz
like Singapore back there and I think
there were probably like 20 30 people
that are interested in crypto and you
keep like seeing the same people in in
the meetups right um so I think uh and
also like we are I think at the same age
and we'll probably like you know uh get
along well with each other so I just
invited him to join the team and who uh
yeah it it was uh great to have him to
support
us uh this might be a bias question CU I
helped to organize a Meetup but you guys
have mentioned meetups a couple times uh
how much have like uh meetups or local
communities helped you guys to form a
team or to like help build your team um
maybe I think in the early days it
definitely helped um I I I'm a strong
believer in having that
human touch like like just um meet in
person because it it it's you you can
tell a lot more about an individual when
you are physically present uh in the
same venue right versus uh online or
like digital
connections
um I would say back in the days there's
um there there was the the difference
between the meetups back then and now um
is that I feel that back then the
attitude towards like ethereum and the
entire sector as a whole was more
innocuous like everyone's in like most
people were in because they wanted to
learn about the tech now it's different
I think the attitude
is what's the next meme coin right
um it kind can't help with that that's
that's the reality um yeah but I think
back in the days to get to know people
people you you go to meet up you find
similar uh you you you you come across
people with similar interests a lot more
easily these days it's harder to tell um
so yeah we probably have to resort to
other other avenues to like streamline
or filter out like how to identify
individuals um who have similar
interests um yeah but I I guess like
that's just a function of time and also
the growth of the sector and uh any
thoughts from Men
L about um utilizing communities local
communities and meetups to help you form
a team or build your
team I think it's
um yeah I mean I think we we actually
like hire several good people from local
meetups right I mean it's um I mean it's
import basically like it's a lot better
it's it's a good like recruitment kind
of like channel for us um you meet
people there you see how they interact
they like you ask them like the the
question that uh basically like usually
like when you meet people you you you
you don't tell them hey we are looking
for this position right but you see like
how they do how they interact with other
people uh what what the characters is
and after that you are like okay this
might be a good fit for the team and you
want to bring them on board and and see
how they um you know I think it's a lot
better than just like proactively like
Ping people yeah
yeah so we support edk right uh we I
probably wouldn't be in stage here uh if
it wasn't because of uh ekl that's where
I kind of met har right uh yeah I think
uh
so the the key for the successful
meetups that we've seen like local
grassroot meetups is it definitely helps
if there is an industry sponsor or
supporter so I think that's what we kind
of uh try to do but at the same time
trying to keep it as nonprofit as
possible so I think that's the the key
point and just providing a space where
if uh people coming back or even people
traveling through the region wants to
stop Buy and they just want to share so
I think having that Meetup uh uh
basically allows you to create a a a a
readily available Community uh that that
is able to share that part I I I think
one thing that I want to add more is
that like I think um I think in
Southeast Asia probably like most people
most Engineers they're very shy like
online right I mean like you go to
Twitter you probably don't see a lot of
like Southeast Asian Engineers talking
about like a lot of stuff like cuz like
one I think English is probably not
their first native language and two
usually they don't they don't argue
online that much right oh yeah they
don't AR you so so so I think the best
way to know them is like to go to like
you know conference or like you know
local meetups in which like there are
some particular topic that is of their
interest and you can like pick a lot of
things from their brain and you know uh
I think they share a lot more
yeah and uh Matt you mentioned you were
15 years as a web tool founder in
Malaysia um I think that's a very unique
um take that you can give that what's
the difference like between being a
Founder in web 2 versus web 3 and
specifically as someone who was in
Malaysia in Southeast
Asia
so so uh it's 15 years in web 2 but 10
years in web tree so 10 years web Tre
right uh is a long time so uh one of the
things I actually realized is uh I I I
have to really think hard because it's
been a while and you kind of get used to
the way things are done in web uh web
tree um but I think this uh something
that kind of reminded me about this was
uh so we were at a dinner and we had a
conversation with this uh person who's
from web to and I think she she actually
shared shared one point uh so she she
shared that uh she's uh moving to web
from Web Two into web three and she said
that one of the things that she found
most St was that uh the people in web
Tre generally especially with ethereum t
we really friendly uh they share a lot
of information uh you know like in web 2
if you go around and ask a lot of stuff
right people kind of get a little bit
hesitant a little bit cautious but if
you see the EOS in batteries if you go
around you ask questions right a lot of
folks are just extremely happy to share
with you to share with you what they're
doing and the the Tex techn so I think
for that matter I I appreciate and I'm
thankful
for being uh being able to be part of
that web tree
itos you you cannot have to be reminded
of that sometimes so I think that was
helpful for me and uh for TN and ly as
well um so you both mentioned that you
were researchers and you did a bunch of
work in the space before you became
Founders so if there's anyone in the
audience or who's watching uh online
like um is that experience how helpful
or necessary is the experience uh to
have before you start and found your own
team um
TI um just a disclaimer my research is
nothing like Mo it's still research
serious research and the hobby is well I
think um my perspective is probably
different from ly I think it helps to
actually like starting out a company is
difficult and in order to I think one
key difference
between a more successful company uh
from everything else is
having a unique perspective itive about
a sector that you're operating in like
for example right A lot of people can be
running money markets very simple
straightforward product with a clear
product Market fit but then there will
be differences between a product like a
and compound and everyone else and of
course like now uh gradually we're
seeing um products like Oiler Moro um
gaining traction these Founders have
very deep understanding about money
markets and they also are able to
incorporate their unique perspective
into their
product that can only come when you are
deep in the in in in the sector like so
like put it simply right if I've not
been involved in the space since my
kyber days I don't think I would be able
to pull out something like
Pendle um that knowledge can come from
research it can come from direct
involvement in a team that is operating
in a certain segment of Interest it can
come from anywhere but really I think
the more
important uh component here is really
deep understanding of the sector and
then developing a unique perspective
that can help develop a more interesting
product a more differentiated one and l
d mention you'll have a very different
perspective um I think in general over
time um I think over the last like 10
years I realized that I think gra tree
is or in general like crypto is um the
most rewarding industry for any academic
researcher right um so it's rewarding
not just because of like the potential
Financial return I mean a lot of like
good high-profile project are run by
academic fers right um but also like you
know seeing being able to see like you
know what you research on to be deployed
to be used by everyone over the world
right I think that's the most rewarding
experience um so before started kyber I
had a few opportunities right to work on
still blockchain research but like in
like say industry uh big companies big
payment companies in the more sorry what
that they that they pay you more I mean
it's not I mean they they they paid okay
I mean it was Visa research right and
they started like their the blockchain
research back in 20177 but I was like
you know if I if I work here uh it's
going to take me years right in order
like to see any of my research like
getting deploy or getting used in
practice and it's going to be like
patent after patents after patents right
uh so that's that's the business model
right um so and then and then I I keep
seeing like you know other people
launching new protocols new product
right and like um I was like I could do
that as well right you know it was a big
inspiration So eventually I decided like
to work on my own startup launch skyber
and get like people to use it and over
time I also encouraged a lot of people
like to hey if you if you want to do
something you know just launch your own
startup right uh like do it in crypto
like forget about fintech forget about
like you know other stuff I think crypto
with crypto you launch for Global
audience you get like abundant of like
funding and support and like you know um
users right from everywhere uh it's the
fastest like you know uh Journey for you
to to see something from happening and
on that note um southeast Asia isn't
very well known for having huge like
globally impacting uh tech companies uh
but we have three here and um just
curious like um do you know like is
there some sort of secret source that
you guys have had that you were able to
create these uh global companies out of
Southeast Asia when a lot of people in a
lot of other industries were unable to
do that um Matt
maybe um so
uh I so I guess that depends on your
personality and the the individual
itself uh for for me specifically uh
generally I I think if you look at for
the same fact that you mentioned right
so if you look at southeast Asia in in
general right uh yeah perhap with the
exception of Singapore uh generally uh
we are often underlooked uh no it's like
you're in South Asia it's not in Silicon
Valley and stuff like that so at least
back back then uh maybe that's that's my
uh chip on on the shoulder so that kind
of motivated me to to uh to prove that
we could build something out here so
that was one one strong driving push
over the over the last 10 years uh to to
show that we could build uh Global
products out out of South Asia uh the
second Point
uh I guess for for us was obviously to
choose uh to choose the work on
something uh that obviously that were
passionate about and and something that
that we had uh and I shared this before
uh that we had a More Level Playing
Field a Level Playing Field meaning that
uh so like with a lot of traditional web
two apps right A lot of it hinges on the
relationships that you had the uh the
geographical location that you based on
like if let's say really fintech and
stuff being in places like New York and
stuff has a lot advantages it is a lot
of font facing consumer apps obviously
being silicon really helps a lot uh so
like uh if we had done something along
those lines it would be wouldn't be on a
fair footing uh so but with B is is a
much more fairer footing it's access to
data decentralized anyone can go out you
can grab it uh you can do whatever you
want with it uh you know and there's
there's yeah you can't control that the
the data is outlow so it's uh everyone
can compete on on a slightly more fairer
basis so I think for us that that was
the the two key points
okay u i mean
no secret
sauce but uh I think so Pendle like my
product is the youngest of um the lot
and I think I've had the fortune of
looking at these two other guys building
Brands and having an influence in the
space and to me that's inspiring because
like like what met said right I think
crypto as a whole
is extremely accessible and the playing
field is a lot more leveled compared to
the other sectors so if when I was
thinking about like building a product I
look at met I look at ly and I thought
that if they're able within southeast
Asia um build
something that can reach a global
audience and attain Global
success I can do it as well so I I I I
look up to these guys
um and I I think it it it helps to also
dream big um just because we're from
Southeast Asia it doesn't mean we're
worse of I actually think there's an
abundant of talents here a lot of us
maybe because of different exposure we
tend to think that it's better out there
but I can say talents wise I mean
there's a plenty right like in Malaysia
and
Vietnam um Singapore is small population
but highly concentrated but like in
Indonesia uh even in Thailand because of
the population and just by the sheer
fact of power of law you have like 600
million people 700 million people here
you can definitely find like the top one
2% to be exceptionally talented right um
so just need to reach out to these
people build something great
and you know given the the fact that
like crypto is extremely democratizing I
think we can build something
great I think um cost plays an important
role here right
um like for startup I mean I'm not sure
about others but I think from my
experience I think we probably have like
to try different ideas before we find
the one that actually works right and
throughout that Journey it's going to
take like one or two years at least
right and like you need to sustain the
team right uh for that one or two years
and I think in in southe Asia it's it's
a lot more cost effective to do that
right um like I mean you can survive in
like Bangkok and probably Hano and K
with like5 $600 per month not sure about
k i I haven't lived there um but yeah I
mean I think you have that ability you
have that like you know um I would say
um yeah Advantage compared to like other
high higher developed uh market and and
you you get to go through like different
like Cycle Products different ideas you
know check them out and see whether
launch it see whether it works if it
works great like let's scale it let's TR
fun right uh if doesn't you know let's
just move on to a new one and also like
one more thing is like Tian mentioned
the the amount of talents the amount of
Engineers here is abundant right like
you know if you want to scale people
probably next month you can get like 10
20 30 more easily um yeah so
and uh staying with ly so if there are
any people who are not from Southeast
Asia and who want to hire devs or other
Talent from out of stheast Asia um they
might have heard you know it's cheap um
they maybe uh some would speak good
English uh they're very hungry uh in
your experience uh working with Talent
out of sest Asia um what would you say
to these uh other builders who might be
interested to uh hire people from
here um with you first working with
sorry what U so if I'm not from
Southeast Asia and I'm looking to hire
someone from here like what would be
some advice or some kind of thoughts I
think you just try to get people from
Pand either scan or kyber that's the
best way
to uh just kidding uh so I mean that
that's what happened to a lot of our
former team members right they got
pushed by other team from elsewhere
basically like say if if if like if the
team is from the US and they're looking
for some people in Asia some engineer in
Asia usually they would look for like
you know all the people that are working
for existing teams in Asia right and
they're like hey we we're going to pay
you double and it's still half the price
that we're paying in the US and we lost
a lot of people to them but it's okay
because like you know it's you know it's
a fair market right uh if they can get a
better opportunity happy for them and uh
we get to work on the on the new
Engineers um but anyway don't do that
uh uh
uh I think in general language is a big
barrier uh but I feel like it's getting
improved a lot lately uh all the young
Engineers because they get to work on
like you know uh English in their
training in the college so Communication
in English inviting is is okay uh
speaking might need some time for them
but I think probably in Malaysia it's
probably it's not on ISU but like in
other countries like Thailand and
Vietnam and even Indonesia it's probably
a big barrier
um other than that I think everyone is
hardworking fast learner young
population you have like you know a lot
of talents to to recruit yeah M yeah so
um first off I I I I don't think 5 600
is enough survive in
K uh second uh tapping off on what uh
lawy has mentioned so so um for that
same reason right uh again generally in
Asia southeast Asia this
uh developing nations right so there's a
high growth and normally uh people here
actually quite hungry right so they uh
they want to improve their lives I'm not
seeing people outside here aren't but
generally in Saudi Asia is very strong
Drive uh the there a strong money there
strong drive also a monetary incentive
in order to improve your quality of life
so people really strive for it I think
they they really work hard and uh they
don't take things to relax uh a lot of
people are just like know you got to
make it so you push hard you study hard
it's very traditional right in Asia
study hard and you work hard and you do
get a good job and stuff like that uh
and
that's fairly uh what what we see at
least in uh developing nations like like
in uh obiously Malaysia and uh Vietnam
and uh Thailand and all the the other
countries with the exception of
Singapore which is obviously already
very uh much more
Global um yeah so um other than that uh
going back to what uh like L
mentioned uh yeah I know uh turnover is
always issue uh again I think it's also
working with uh teammates that now say
money is important but I think there are
also other values there uh other things
that you can accomplish working in a
team so yes money plays a large factor I
don't think it's the the the only Factor
uh sometimes it's also about a journey
and uh the ability to grow and probably
thinking a little bit more forward know
like U what happens after 5 years and
and stuff like that and there will be a
bunch of other reasons that we can do it
in a separate
conversation
K oh no nothing meaningful to add I
think they covered all and I think the
stereotypes gener quite
accurate okay then I'm not going to let
you go um but the talent within South
southeast Asia uh is extremely diverse
all right because um Singapore Malaysia
uh Vietnam Thailand uh Indonesia
Philippines all very different uh people
and uh you I'm quite sure that three of
you hire like people from across the
region um so what are your kind of
learnings from handling these very diff
very diverse cultures within the C
team yeah I'm going to start with you
cuz you skipped the last one
yeah can I defer to Matt okay Matt first
let me go ahead and take a step with
that because we're actually quite uh
diverse
culturally uh so again uh Malaysia is in
the middle of everything right uh the
three main different groups and uh races
right
uh
so uh I I I I I actually think diversity
is a strend uh I know it's always been
said it sounds cliche but I think it is
uh it is especially when it comes to
again I guess what we're building right
so for us some of the stuff were
buildings a little bit more front-facing
so I think having perspective from
different folks from different
backgrounds and different perceptions I
think helps right so uh know you if
we're building something and someone
says this looks this color looks good
and someone else says this color looks
uh not so good so I actually found a lot
of it has some sort of cultural cultural
elements for for for what it is uh and
somehow we able to to drive on a color
that's a little bit new more neutral so
that kind of works for us uh having said
that other than that uh nothing critical
uh you know very minor stuff uh probably
like in uh so let's say like this trip
we're making here with the team right so
I guess know what you know what's you
know what is actually our biggest
challenge or not so our biggest
challenge is actually figuring out where
to go eat uh the reason being you know
coming from different typerse
backgrounds you know that like food
requirements for example uh maybe it has
to be uh ker or or Halal or you know or
maybe it has to be no alcohol and stuff
like that so actually this very trival
stuff and somehow we we actually manage
and we really find balance no and there
are sessions where it's uh with alcohol
and the sessions without alcohol and why
and someh it works and I think a lot of
folks it's a very unique unique
perspective one that I I I've grown up
with and I I treasure a lot Yeah you
mentioned to me earlier diversity by
default so I think it's a good catch
phase it is what it is um okay TI are
you ready no I I really don't see like
major challenges I think managing
diversity is part impossible of running
a running a team um this happens
regardless of where you're at and of
course like southeast Asia is relatively
diverse but there's also a lot of
similarities in the way
we um perceive things um I think yeah by
and
large yeah Southeast Asians are
generally motivated um and having that
shared trade is is helpful in trying to
align team members uh everybody wants to
win so so you just have to do a bit of
reminder and I think everyone can fall
in line quite
quickly
like I would say if you if you want to
uh I mean I think the probably the best
way to do that is to probably like have
a trusted leader or manager in every
country and you just like deal with that
person right and rely on that person to
manage the team in that particular
country uh I think we do that because
like back then kba had people in like
Vietnam Singapore and like Israel and
couple of other countries cuz I think
there are a lot of things that you don't
know about the culture about how people
want and what people want right and I
think having someone that you can rely
on and to handle all of that issues for
you and make sure that everyone works
well together I think is is
great all right and um this question
I've had from a lot of people uh
actually um not sure by coincidence or
by Design but uh somehow um so kyber and
Pendle are very very strong companies in
Defi and ether scan and Co Geo for
example are very very strong in kind of
data services uh is there a reason why
soueast Asia um is birthing these
champions in these two specific uh
spaces within the industry uh does
anyone here have an answer I'll speak on
behalf of uh Malaysia
uh I think a lot of us don't want to end
up in jail last
time so we we chose the data which is
much more clearer uh right now it's not
too bad the regulatory landscape is
there's a lot more clarity and I know
it's just you go early into the space
and like like normally typical
Malaysians you know we we have families
and stuff like that so uh so yeah so we
just want to navigate and also I think
you know navigate in area that's
considered relatively straightforward uh
because you know there's just just
different licenses and AML kyc and stuff
you need to go into so uh given that it
wasn't clear for us specifically uh so
we choose we chose that that part so
which is why you have like goingo and
scan doing quite similar products with
data that doesn't really touch the uh
transaction flow like uh both of these
guys are doing
now I think for me it's a a little
different like I I somehow found my way
to Singapore and like Singapore being a
financial Hub uh in the region and also
um I think one of the more important
Financial hubs globally we have a lot of
exposure
to financial products and instruments
and that has of course shaped how I
think about finance and it so happened
that defi is one of the major narratives
Within crypto in the early days and it
continues to be the major driver of
adoption
so it helps I think like from from a I
think a product operator standpoint um
just being physically in Singapore um
the access to Capital um the knowledge
in financial infrastructure definitely
helps how we think about product
construct
now I I am Malaysian by
nationality and um as to how like some
of these def5 products are can be traced
to Malaysian Founders I I'm not
sure I think I can add a little bit I
think it's probably a little bit broader
right um I think the reason why we see a
lot of like say def defy and like data
oriented products coming out sou Asia is
because sou Asian Founders are bad at
selling
right so we have like to build something
that the product will sell for itself
right so like defy product Market fit
instantly from day one right data
product is the same everyone use ether
scan these days because it's just the
right product that people want we are
bad at selling a new narrative it's
really hard for servation to do that
right I mean it's not just because we I
mean English is not our native language
it's it's also because we don't have
like big funds like A6 Z product to Stam
like $1 100 million us check on us and
said this is the new narrative right in
South Asia we don't have that big of the
funds um so we have like to pick
something that I think is product Market
fit can generate Revenue can get users
from day one and we can just scale right
from
there all right so uh we have a little
bit of time left um this panel is called
debunking myths um building out of sea
so I want to check with you guys very
quickly answer uh each one of you uh
whether each item is a truth or a myth
uh so first item um funding uh how
whether it's very difficult to get
funding out of the country that you are
based out of um Kyro just mentioned the
country and Truth or
myth Vietnam I think it's a bit hard
Singapore um a lot easier
yeah yeah same uh Malaysia is a little
bit more challenging Singapore is
easy same
yeah um okay um infrastructure um
whether it's the internet uh having
highways uh having a strong like startup
ecosystem um is it lacking or is it um
actually
thriving uh ly we'll just go in Cycles
internet I think it's good I think
internet in South Asia is actually
extremely good compared to many other
part of the world um
startup ecosystem I think it's still
growing uh it's not there yet but it's
growing yeah and as a city like highways
buildings I think it's okay I mean yeah
so Malaysia uh no no no issues very
strong infrastructure good buildings
relatively in comparison good roads uh
and in terms of the internet
connectivity it's uh uh decent very
decent so I say
it that's uh me that yeah I guess like
it it really varies from City to city
right so if you look at Singapore it's
definitely like pretty top-notch in
public infrastructure Transportation
internet everything is good KL is also
like pretty high up there but when it
comes to Jakarta for example um it's
extremely renowned
for like traffic like massive traffic
gam uh internet connectivity I guess
it's good
um but a lot of time like if you were to
do a business in Jakarta a lot of time
will be wasted in trying to get from one
spot to the other um so I I think I um
in Southeast Asia it depends on where
you go okay and this one is just for TN
um well la as well because you spend
time in Singapore but Singapore cost
very very high truth or
myth myth I think Singapore yeah yes in
terms of published reports the cost is
actually very high but the good thing
about Singapore is that there's always a
range so if you want to like take
transportation for example
establish public transport is actually
extremely affordable but if you want to
own a car it's going to cost a lot of
money in the same way when it comes to
food and daily
necessity you you have like extremely
affordable option with like2 $3 US
dollar a day you can uh sorry a meal you
can find something very um yeah it can
feel your tummy but of course if you
want find dining a three star restaurant
will cost you $1,000 something like that
right
um yeah so that's that's how I think
about
Singapore Lor since you spend some time
there if you just leave that alone it's
very okay it's affordable right but if
you need to say build a family or build
a team there it's going to be very
costly very costly um yeah but I think
back to the previous question I think
Singapore is probably the most developed
like you know start Hub in terms of like
ecosystem right like you have like funds
you have like quality fers you have
people like visiting the country every
now and then so I think it's a vibrant
uh crypto startup Hub in uh in Southeast
Asia I think a other countries probably
don't have that that luxury that um you
know that intersection of people from
Over the all over the world try to stay
there for a few months learn the
ecosystem try to expand to South Asia or
Asia in general and they they would want
to set up base in Singapore um yes all
right and a couple questions before we
open it up for the audience um for
people who are not from SV East Asia who
are considering to move here to build a
team or to join the team uh any quick
advice uh each one of you can give
them T
first go to
Malaysia what go go go to Malaysia why
it's uh like reliable infrastructure
causes a fraction of that of Singapore
and you get good access to many many
parts of the world oh maybe I add it so
team is in Malaysia the founders are in
Singapore that's what we're seeing right
now raise the capital in Singapore and
do the work in
k um I would say you need to pick a base
right I mean I think there are several
good base in Southeast Asia uh k um
Bangkok and Hanoi hoim Ming yeah uh
Singapore as well um but of course like
you know if you're in Singapore you have
like to you know uh know what you want
to achieve from there right cuz the cost
is High um but if you want to build a
team and engineering team K very good I
I think even uh uh Vietnam actually Han
hoim is very active Hano you can get
great Engineers too great Engineers yeah
yeah I I also want to add okay so the
reason why I thought about Malaysia
right is because I think the yeah
English the the general English
Proficiency in Malaysia is is quite good
it was an English colony um so English
is can get you yeah quite quite uh far
but think engineering Talent Hanoi
Vietnam of course saon yeah of course
does make sense yeah no no contest all
right uh thanks for the panelist that's
all my questions and uh we can open it
up for audience um to ask their question
thank you so much can we give a big
round of applause to the
panel that was awesome okay so we're
into Q&A uh if you don't know how to do
or participate you just need to take a
snap of that QR code you scroll to the
bottom of the page and there's a link
saying live Q&A and yeah just click the
Q&A button and you'll be able to put up
some questions so let's get straight
into some of the questions that are on
the screen here uh the first one is do
you see that there is a bigger wave of
adoption of crypto in APAC now any one
of the panelists can answer or
several I I could say um there are a lot
more young people trading crypto than
trading stocks these days in South Asia
um because I think it's just easy to
understand for them it's very easy to
set it up and just you know yeah I think
so I mean I agree with the point um uh
Singapore Vietnam probably Vietnam
especially right
um the number of number of active users
on say like crypto
exchanges um is up only um and I think I
think it's because yeah it's just a lot
more accessible and like all these
exchanges are putting strong efforts in
trying to grow their presence and
markets in in several countries in
Southeast Asia
um and I think like regulation is
getting better in a lot of the countries
like um I think as I I I just met like
someone from SCB uh the the biggest bank
here I think uh they they launch an app
for you to convert your usdc to tyat and
you can just spend immediately at the
merchants it's crazy um in Singapore
there are a lot of like crypto payment
company now as well like you can just
pay from like cash out your crypto into
the debit card and you can just pay from
the debit card I mean it's it's getting
to the point that I don't even need like
to uh you know use my bank for most of
the transaction these days
yeah all right great thank you um let's
move on to the next question uh are you
guys
hiring oh yeah so the next question you
guys uh are you guys hiring wait I
thought it was the other one well
apparently this one is very
popular uh let me jump to the other one
the city okay well we can just get yes
or Nos and then we can move on yeah
hiring uh yeah obviously we're hiring
yeah okay ether scans hiring I'm sure
you're looking for good talents I I Rec
I recently started a caliber Ventures
Builder as well so if you are looking
for to do your own startup uh talk to me
um I only do like two every year so you
know you're hiring two people
now we're looking actively for new fers
yeah yeah okay yeah for us like in short
yes we are always on the lookout for
talents um positions varies
thank you all right um okay so earlier
part of the conversation I think New
York was mentioned as a city that has
like high kind of FaceTime networking
maybe networking opportunities have been
less in Southeast Asia and also someone
in the panel mentioned that Southeast
Asian don't like arguing online as much
so um the question is what are some tips
that you have um for people here based
in Southeast Asia to better tap into
like the global or online networ netw
working for web
3 so we don't like arguing so uh I I I
would say it's actually changing so I've
seen uh I don't know maybe it's
a well actually I guess like for us uh
that's one of the challenges like
actually going out there and and
creating that awareness and arguing
online uh somehow it just goes against
that whole uh but having said I think
we've seen uh some of the newer project
so I think so we actually had this
conversation just recently so this
project uh I think uh Mega just founder
uh brother Ving what so I think she has
a very strong presence and is able to
capture so I that that that perception
is changing a lot of the the projects
coming out I able to do a good job yet
and hopefully we can can learn a little
bit on how that's
done so I guess it's like about gaining
more of ibility online any other sort of
networking
tips maybe I can chip in as well uh so
what we found with the local community
in KL is uh for the young people
especially just join hackathons there
are a bunch of online hackathons and the
price pool can be quite big uh so
there's a kind a cohort of Builders who
just join these hacker thoughts and uh
use the winnings to go fund uh
themselves to go to the next hackathons
and from there you're introducing to
People based on what you've built and
not based on uh what you're talking
about yeah I guess another way is to
also Joy all the big project big
companies in the region right and from
time to time we need to send people to
uh events conferences to learn what
others are building right um so that's
also a good opportunity for you to
network and to basically like you know
learn from the
best okay great I think that segue is
nicely to the next question which is
what are the best community ities in
your opinion uh to connect with other
Founders in each of your
cities
e speak damn I got to show you e k yes
for kale uh and then crypto crypto SG uh
for like yeah basically I think anyone
who is building something independent of
sectors or ecosystem would would would
have uh some form of connection with uh
Nick and his
team wearing the a uh it's a crypto
Community South Asia oh yeah yeah it's
actually quite interesting quite vibrant
uh they talk crypto all the time like
even like playing soccer like some guys
trading meme coin on the
bench so it's like you know it's it's
crazy even in Malaysia uh the paji paji
community is quite
strong great thank thank you um got a
couple more questions here how is
someone not to be overlooked as a deeply
technical person moving to Southeast
Asia from America what should they do so
go you know online versus meetups or
practical Tech versus networking
people so someone's moving from America
to Southeast Asia how can they stand out
and not be overlooked be like
Ross no I'm just kidding n person he was
security right so
uh no I think yeah uh meetups definitely
uh when when we first started out like
even in cicon Valley in 2015 2016 the
way we uh connected with the community
that uh back then there was through
meetups so I think the the same still
holds through here go for for meetups
it's free it's
informal anything else to
add I yeah I mean just try to
participate right try to give talk try
to you know be part of some team and I
think like in general we are very happy
to meet new people uh if you are in to
just you know uh pingers and ask for
meet ask for meeting or office tour or
something happy to meet new people all
the time yeah great so um let's talk
about the bull market um what are you
guys excited to see in the cycle of the
bull market and if you'd like to add
anything like on the Southeast Asian
point of view like what do you think or
how do you think it may impact southeast
Asia so generally as well as like focus
on southeast
Asia I guess like um yeah with with W
Market we can expect
more new
joiners
um
and with with more new joiners I think
it's also reasonable to expect newer and
creative use cases that might be native
to Southeast Asia um after all I think
from um media consumption
perspective people in Southeast Asia
consume media very differently from many
many nationalities in other parts of the
world
so I would imagine that um people who
are native to Southeast Asia will take
opportunities perhaps a bit different ly
from um yeah um individuals in other
nationality uh in in in other countries
uh maybe things that are yeah I I
wouldn't be surprised if there are
things that are native to say like
Vietnam that might not have a lot of
adoption outside of the country uh exact
use case hard to say but I think this is
a reasonable
expectation okay I think this like oh
man if you want to add no okay I think I
think there's a slightly similar
question which is maybe connected which
is what should people build here any
ideas like the kind of daps or even the
infrastructure built in Southeast Asia I
think end of the day you have to uh
really like see what's your strength
what's your weakness right and uh like
who do you have in the team um and and
and decide on the product that that that
really fit to your background um we
actually spend a lot of time like
talking to the poers and also like try
to analyze and help them realize what
should be the best thing for them to
build um and of course like if they get
like advisor like talk to people like
Tenn and Matt and see what they are what
they think is cool to build I think it's
also like a good source up like ideas um
yeah so just want to add there uh choose
something that
you're passionate about and that you're
good
at go for those two and you have a very
High chance of success regardless of
what it
is thank you okay well unfortunately
we've run out of time uh thank you so
much to everyone who's put up questions
um maybe feel free to talk to the
speakers after this um this panel's over
so let's give a big round of applause to
our panelists it's been awesome to have
you guys
[Music]
all right thank you for being a great
audience it's been awesome to see
everyone thanks for the great questions
we have more exciting content coming up
next we've got another panel which is
super interesting how crypto is used in
Africa today here from leading Builders
so please don't go anywhere um thank you
so much for your participation this is
my last session for this morning so
thank you for being a great audience I'm
Deborah and I'll see you again soon
[Music]
hello can you hear me yes hello my name
is Mark and welcome to this uh next
session in the real world ethereum so
this is we've got an awesome panel group
of people here to talk about how crypto
is used in Africa today here from our
leading
Builders so remember the uh you know the
drill now the QR code create some
questions we'll have 10 minutes at the
end for a good lot of questions so
without further Ado I'll introduce the
panelists so we
have y Damaris David Y and Yosef welcome
to the
[Applause]
[Music]
stage hello def conon
hello thanks so much for joining us uh
on this very exciting panel discussion
um we're going to be talking about
exactly how web Tre is being used in
Africa today and what are the types of
Innovations people are building uh early
this week we covered uh two really
interesting threads of the impact of
crypto on one side it is plugging
African countries and economies into the
global economy that has been a hyper
globalizing impact and effect that
traditional systems have kind of failed
us and we'll hear from Founders who are
basically at the Leading Edge of that
movement in plugging payments banking
infrastructure but also other services
that we need to live our lives uh into
the broader global economy and on the
other side there's a lot of amazing
opportunities to go even more local than
where we are going today and we're going
to hear about the hyper localization
impact that perhaps were not possible to
do in this way before blockchain
Technologies became a thing so I'm very
excited to have an amazing group of
people to cover these threads with us
we're going to do a very brief round of
introductions and we're going to jump
straight into the deep end uh Jambi do
you want to introduce yourself yes my
name is Jambi jurug I work for
Grassroots economics Foundation been
working for the organization uh for the
last six years now I am an advocate for
Community inclusion currencies for
poverty eradication and sustainable
development super happy to be here and
where you from I'm from Nairobi but I
live in kifi and that is also where I
work nice if you guys have never been to
East Africa kif is an incredible place
to
visit everyone
thing one two awesome hey everyone my
name is David nandell I'm CEO and CTO of
a business called honey coin and Pier we
are B2B Toc Financial super app and
Treasury and payments platform I'm based
out of Nairobi Kenya and like super
excited to be here and thank you for all
being in the room thank you hey everyone
uh my name is y bosi um I'm the
co-creator of onboard we're building a
borderless digital money app for people
in the global majority markets with a
universal um on and off ramp Gateway
that allows anyone come on chain with
his little to l 50 cents whilst paying
zero fees um I leave in um Lagos and
London um but I call myself an African
onchain if you're wondering why I'm
wearing a pirate um costume today I'm
currently pirate uru which means freedom
in Swahili and essentially um I'm
spreading the freedom of money so thanks
for having me thank you so uh David I I
want to start off with you and we just
love to understand what is the problem
that you guys are really focused on when
it comes to payments and what is the gap
that a project like yours is filling and
and what's the scale of opportunity that
exists there yeah I know that's a really
good question I think it really like
sets the context for you know this
conversation in general like I would say
for us the main problem we solving is
when you look at a continent any
continent you take any particular
continent Africa has over like 45 plus
countries we're pretty much addressing
the fragmentation problem and the fact
that the largest players on a financial
stack like banks are not incentivized to
solve that fragmentation problem if
anything they benefit from it right um
they benefit from the fact that someone
in Kenya cannot do business with someone
in Nigeria unless they're doing it
through them and they're going to make
sure that like they'll milk as much
value from them when that money is
moving almost as if you're traveling
physically you know to that particular
market and by solving and addressing
that fragmentation problem we strongly
believe that as we build that plumbing
which is like this pipeline it's almost
like a hyper tunnel between different
markets between different corridors we
then now actually incentivize people to
connect do business with each other
actually have conversations on
collaboration and partnership so I see
our work as important as you know in the
US during the Industrial Revolution when
they were putting in the railroads to
connect different cities uh across
States and so on and so forth and um I
think if we succeed if we win and and
why this problem is so crucial to solve
is as I mentioned in the beginning
there's very few players who are
incentivized to solve it because their
incentives lie in the issue we see the
incentives as being much larger than the
issue because when you actually create
the initial Plumbing what you do is you
open up a world of different use cases
um and and and in different ways that
people will now start to like actually
think of you know how do I benefit and
profit from this outside of just like
I'll profit of you having a very painful
problem I like the analogy of plumbing
and railroads those are like the Bas
layer infrastructure that everything
relies on can you like give us even more
concrete examples of why is that broken
right now like with the lack of those
infrastructures how is value moving
around and and what are the pain points
in like in real
terms yeah yeah yeah no that's a good
question as well a good followup I mean
like I think to give you guys some
context right now most banks don't even
on own the software that they're running
their banking infrastructure on and I
I'll I'll frequently use the Bank use
case because even if you were trying to
build a web to fintech and your partner
was like a core Bank in X market and
they had access to all of these
different regions you're basically just
connecting to a pipe that's already
leaking and trying to see how you can
layer on an additional solution like so
uh that context like the context of why
we're in treasury why we're in payments
why we're building a super app is we
have to we're basically coming in to in
a way way like not build around but web3
and blockchain Technology gives us the
ability to give the banks to give the
licensed payment service providers to
give the licensed financial institutions
this infrastructure which is highly
scalable we can allow money to move at
the speed of the internet which is
extremely crucial but then also we can
in it's almost like in parallel we're
not competing with you but down the road
the the end goal is for you to stop
being competitor it's for you to be our
customer right and um most of the people
that we work with are I mentioned the
banks the licensed FIS the licensed
payment service providers they're those
people because like we believe that
initial Beach head will create
opportunities for us to like permeate
this technology permeate the stable coin
payment use cases the um blockchain
payment use cases around on and off
ramping to like the broader majority of
people in on the continent and it starts
though with the folks who have already
you know deeply embedded themselves with
what's broken within the financial
system especially on the continent it's
fragmentation one it's you know white
labeling software another it's you know
just bad you know code and like um
Legacy web to technology on the third
tier and and all of those things is kind
of like how I think we now get to scale
but we have to first start there and
that's kind of like I would say the
impact to which we're working with these
different license fi Banks and PSPs and
Y you've been been in the space for a
long period of time trying to Sol
fintech before crypto and then with
crypto trying to Sol payment and like I
would love to hear what are the patterns
that you've seen on the continent so
far so I think um ysph talked about this
idea of context and so I I want to help
everyone level
set imagine if the US dollar lost 90% of
the value or whatever currency or Fiat
that you had so you could you had I
don't know $11,000 in whatever currency
and then today the
value after two years is now
$100 due to no fault of your own or for
most people they don't even have money
yet right so they can't even come into
the financial system because they don't
have any money right so if you look at
the world today over 2.5 billion people
are living on less than 50 cents a day
2.5 billion people and these are people
that live in global majority markets so
we're looking at like Africa laam um
southeast Asia India and unfortunately
the world is still
broken and you know when I when I first
got into crypto I got into crypto
because I was fortunate enough to have
been part of an early exit in
2015 or
2016 um and began to support
entrepreneurs in the web two space and
what I realized was two things it wasn't
because of talent that some of these
ideas weren't working it was primarily
two things number one was the
foundational infrastructure that we were
trying to build this Financial Solutions
on were broken it was a combination of
institutional problems it was a
combination of um sort of weak
currencies and then also policies as
well right um and when I first looked at
the blockchain I thought like wow okay
this is something that we can use to
really rebuild Financial infrastructure
from the ground up and equalize access
to Opportunities regardless of where
you're from and so um it's been really
interesting seeing the rise of stable
coins and you know everyone now is
talking about stable coins and it's like
okay finally everyone gets it right
because you know people complicate
stable coins but I think of stable coins
as essentially putting the US Dollar on
the internet and the same way how when
you don't understand or have you're
trying to learn something you can Google
it and then you have access to that
information immediately when you do the
same thing to finance a lot of positive
things will happen and so
um but yeah that's sort of you know just
a little bit of context and you know why
I've been um building and really excited
to to contribute to this space so a few
weeks ago actually CH analysis came out
with a report of crypto use across the
world and one of the stats they put out
there that is that for uh traditional
payments to move money from one country
to another and we keep talking about
that because Africa is a continent
54 countries and so whenever you're
Crossing value across any of those
borders um you're running to a lot of
Swift Swift and Global Financial system
challenges so if you're Crossing value
across borders I mean information cross
borders very easily right but when value
crosses
borders you're taking a 15% haircut 15
that's what CH analysis put out there um
other reports that I've seen show you
know in real life it's around 8 to 9%
depending on how much value you're going
and like David just even knowing what
hinein is doing I love to understand a
bit of the the types of customers that
are coming and using your infrastructure
to plug in the global economy because
these are not like crypto Fanatics these
are not people who are coming to Defcon
or crypto conferences these are people
running the traditional economy right so
can you just share a bit about like why
are they coming to you what are they
getting from you that they're not able
to get elsewhere yeah yeah I think um
and and you know it's it's it's it's
it's literally what fuels me to keep
going um I think a larger percentage of
our customers are non- crypto non web3
companies then they are like just
traditional web3 companies um and at the
moment we're serving some of the larger
Enterprises like I'm talking um you know
traditional fmcg or like retail the
likes of bidco uni um on the banking
side of things we're working very
closely with you know the United Bank of
Africa the equity Banks um the brex say
Columns of this world um if you're in
the US as well and the reason I use the
two partners that I mentioned but then
more so like these core customer use
cases there's businesses in logistics
who are literally moving physical goods
from Kenya to Tanzania from Tanzania to
South Africa and and back um and and
these these folks chose us
because uh and I I like to always use
this analogy they chose us
because uh Financial infrastructure and
financial platforms were left in the
'90s in Africa and we're trying to you
know help them catch up right and to
give you context of what catching up
actually looks like before a provider
like us and there's a number of
different providers and you guys are
welcome to do your research
I would have to go to my bank fill in a
physical remittance form that's what we
call it uh just to pay for like an
invoice in a country that is probably uh
100 a couple of 100 kilometers between
each other right that should not exist
in 2024 but it does and and that's why a
customer like them would choose us um
the second reason they would choose us
is we offer kind of like a more
refreshing experience to what they're
used to in that the person you're
serving not the person that is serving
you um if they were an fx broker if they
were a bank if they were uh web to
fintech as well who I have nothing
against to be honest um the person
that's serving you would kind of like be
offering you a solution and it's as if
they're doing your favor right like you
ask you know the exchange rate on Google
is this why are you selling to me
dollars at this price I'll tell you this
is the price of the day right there's
nothing you can do um and I think one of
the non-negotiable rights is optionality
as a human in general like you should
get to choose you shouldn't be told this
is what you know exists this is how life
is and so you should just go ahead and
take it um and we're giving optionality
not just from like a platform
perspective like you can use us and but
we're giving optionality on a more
deeper level in terms of like look we
are not trying to sell you the same
thing that has been sold in this market
with the tier One banks with the largest
FIS largest PSPs I think back to like
one of the more you know even funnier
scenarios that it just happened to us
this week like we onboarded a payment
service provide a customer on Monday and
Tuesday they want to call it my head of
products and they were literally
pitching you know our platform to their
customers right that's the kind of like
I would say catalyst that excites me the
most because it's like this person is so
excited about what's happening with
folks like us um with the onboards with
the grassroot economics that they're
literally like I will put you in front
of my customers and tell them look it's
better now or it works you know it's
efficient it's faster um and those are
all very colorful adjectives but I think
the tangibility of them is in those kind
of like very traditional customers who
would never touch crypto but if you
bring it to them in a way that actually
addresses the solution then you're
solving a major problem it's interesting
what I've heard you say is that you're
you're not saying hey like let's destroy
Banks let's recreate that you're
actually saying let us bring a new value
proposition that they're not able to
do integrate with them because they have
different types of distributions but
create superpowers from money and build
on top of them and like build the
plumbing of like the Global Financial
system and I guess one quick thing I
wanted to kind of plug in there is that
when many of us keep talking about
financial service applications a lot of
folks ask what is beyond Finance what
are innovations that we should do Beyond
finance and what comes to mind for me
when you know we talk that is of course
we need to look at Beyond Finance but if
today for
example for people in California
paying something on the same website the
same project in based in Texas if that
took four
weeks and if you're paying 15% extra and
that was the case for all 50 plus states
in the US of actually moving value
between all those States was so hard and
basically if you are flying halfway on
the plane you had to change your
monetary system right like I think we'll
probably all drop everything and work on
solving that problem right that's the
problem that we're trying to solve from
financial application perspective across
Africa and the reason why we keep
focusing on it a lot is because it is
like where is it's like the the the the
the train tracks as you put it that
connects the foundations of a lot of our
economies and once we have a better
infrastructure there we can build a
whole lot of things on top of that but
we keep coming back to the base layer
which is transfer of value is because
there's fundamental problems there
and and over to you y on that like the
onboard vision is building a fully
onchain life and I'll just love to
understand a bit of how did you get to
that place and what is a what does the
world look like when once we fully
realized that
Vision yeah um I really loved the
example you gave of like the US and
Texas and all that I think it really
does help understand you know what's
happening on the ground in in Africa um
like I said earlier Talent is evenly
distributed but opportuni is
not and I think that when we talk about
this idea of a global onchain
economy what is powerful about that idea
is that it makes it doesn't make your
geography determine the quality of your
life right we want to make your location
Irrelevant in terms of the opportunities
that you have access to in terms of the
quality of financial services they have
access to um and really building an
economy that is open that is transparent
and is
meritocratic um we actually live in the
world of
abundance right it's just that you know
that abundance is not um freely spread
and that's why you have so many people
in in in in in poverty and we know the
reason why we all
feel upset and unhappy about the state
of the world today is because we know
that the current system just doesn't
work a lot of people don't have um sort
of their fair share or don't feel like
they have agency about how to change and
improve their lives and this is kind of
like what is creating a lot of the
divisions and uncertainty and
unhappiness regardless of where people
are from and so
to me the the the idea of an un economy
I know you know someone like elos says
he wants to take Humanity to Mars and
that's like an ambitious vision and it's
like okay we're going to have rocket
ships that will take everybody to Mars
and I think like that's that's amazing
but what if you just build an actual
unchain economy that is better than what
we have today right and you know for
instance I'll give you an
example um I haven't said this public
public Al but I feel a bit comfortable
saying this now like my
personal um accounts were were were
blocked um over the last couple of
months right and if there wasn't any
crypto I would have been
really been in a very bad place right so
the fact that I had stable coins and I
had my keys gave me that agency and gave
me that freedom of money that it doesn't
matter where I'm from and even if I you
know I've been been in Thailand for the
last couple of weeks I've been spending
my stable coins with a with a with a
card to pay for grab and jumping on
motorcycle taxes that I've never entered
before when I go to the US it's the same
thing on Uber when I traveled when I
went to e on Brussels was the same thing
so when when an individual has control
over their money and is on
chain you know it doesn't matter sort of
where they are they can move spend
freely build on reputation you know a
lot of people in emergin markets don't
have a credit score right imagine if in
the US or in Europe for you to buy a
phone you had to pay for it upfront at
once if you wanted to get a house you
have to pay for it offering at once when
to go to university P it offer at once
so actually in a lot of global majority
markets it's not that people are poor
it's the fact that they cannot actually
leverage their reputation to get access
to Capital to build future for
themselves right and so to me the UN
economy is giving everybody access to
the same Global world-class Financial
Services giving everybody control and
freedom of their money giving everybody
control of their own unchaining
reputation think about it as a credit
score that then truly unlocks a whole
host of opportuni ities and they are
fully empowered to create a better
future not just for themselves for the
world around them thank you yeah and and
and I guess the importance of that just
even bring it down to specifics in
Nigeria uh GitHub came out with a report
earlier like later last year there's
about
900,000 plus uh uh open source
contributors on GitHub alone right so
the GitHub page is their resume it's not
their LinkedIn because no one will hire
like just to be very blunt people don't
like to hire Nigerians all around the
world unless they know them personally
right but stuff like that is actually
making it more meritocratic and those
guys are receiving income and salary in
what way like it is really hard to send
money from elsewhere to Nigeria like
PayPal doesn't like to work in Nigeria
stripe doesn't work in Nigeria right so
the plumbing is broken right and so this
is not just like a nice to have it's a
plan a for a whole lot of folks right so
yeah I mean and and and the other bit of
what I think what you guys are building
which is very interesting there are
quite a few like other builders doing
this is you're moving Fiat to stablecoin
and then in a self- cust or caded wallet
and then you have a digital debit card
they can actually use that to spend
internationally because your local banks
have a limit of how much money you can
spend how much is it in Nigeria right
now uh it's probably there was a time
when it was really bad and it was like
$20 a month $20 a month so even if even
if you had like thousands of dollars you
could only spend $20 a month and you
couldn't even go to the bank and be like
oh I have you know $1,000 or $2,000 I
want to redraw it it's like you can't
redraw that money right so um or your
your or your dollar card won't even work
on some websites you know um just
because the the the underlying Plumbing
wasn't working and that's why people
and businesses have turned to stable
coins because it it dis
intermediates it's like you as a person
you have the dollars but the financial
infrastructure is so broken that is
preventing you from connecting with the
global economy and with stable coins and
and blockchains it's like
okay Mr Bank get the F we don't need you
we're just going to connect directly to
the global economy and transact freely
um and that's kind of yeah that's the F
that's it's not even the future it's
like the future is here it's just not
evenly distributed you know so if you
guys and a whole lot of other builders
are radically successful what we're
basically doing is we are building the
plumbing for our economies to easily
integrate with the rest of the world our
location is not a
liability but it's part of who we are
it's our culture but that is not
stopping us from fully fully
participating contributing benefiting
from the global World let us change the
gear a little bit and come local we've
got Jambi here who's building one of the
most exciting uh initiatives uh in Kenya
uh can you tell us a little bit about
how you see the world and what what you
guys are building with Grassroots
economics yes uh thank you so much um we
have been working on a nice economic uh
protocol called commitment pooling so
it's h being it's inspired by um
indigenous wisdom so when I talk about
indigenous wisdom I mean um Traditions
around mucho Aid and mostly rotation of
Labor
Association um so what we have noticed
is that it's not a New Concept it's been
there for ages and ac across um Nations
you know so like in my Community we call
it muia um you know we work with Kenya
Red Cross at the refugee centers and the
Somali call it go you know the guys from
Burundi call
it and every other community in Kenya
like have a name for it so it's not new
so what you're doing as an organization
is really um adding you know formalizing
commitments cuz rotation of Labor really
meant making promises to help one
another and these promises are really
commitments and I'm going to give you a
good example
like in a village X there's family a
family B family C so family a will make
family all the families will make
commitments to help one another and then
they're going to pull their commitments
together uh to to bring about exchanging
and accountability with agreed upon
rules so if family a needs a house built
that means family b and c will come and
help family a so they will fulfill their
commitments you know then family a has
already accepted the commitments so
family B will do the same they will
accept commitments from family B and C
and they will get their farm tilled so
that means they have um a and C has
fulfilled their commitments to B
eventually they will balance out and
clear the debt and start over again so
um this whole uh protocol is not just
with the humans like it's across
disciplines and you know I would give
one example of the plants just to show
you how grass economics is coming in um
like the maze the beans and the Squash
you know for the longest time our
ancestors have been growing them
together because of the nutrients that
they share um we see how the maze will
bring the phosphorus you know the the
beans will get the nutrient nitrogen
from the air convert it and um they
squash the potassium so the sharing is
is is U made possible like how much of
the phosphorus does the squash need need
so that is made possible by the micis of
fungi so now the pulling aspect is now
the micro of fungi uh what Grassroots
economics is doing so these commitments
Grassroots is uh formalizing them adding
technology you know making them have a
value number one number two they have a
special signature you can't copy them
number three um there's a demor a
deduction to make sure that um
circulation and also to make sure that
the holder of you know these commitments
can um Can can convert them from the
issuer of the debt you know so that's
the whole idea like grass economics you
know formalizing this and helping make a
pool where community members can put in
their commitments and pull out
um what they need you know also bringing
out the aspect of of resilience because
if for instance I do not need what you
have what you have and maybe you need
mine I can use your commitments to get
something else from the pooling yes
amazing um and can you share a bit about
the the types of commitments people are
saying hey I will do ABCD and also just
give us a bit of an indication what is
the scale of of operation that is
happening in this way right now so um
I'm going to give you a good example of
where I come from um I come from kifi
and uh from my community I'm in three
groups so group one um is a group of
women um they already have you know
formed a group they have their own
Vision um you know they have their own
rules a constitution so the idea when
you go to a community is for them to
understand the different assets that are
in the community for them to understand
they have a lot to share like the you
know the social assets the financial
assets the governance assets at what
level is each one of them and how can
they help one another so you in these
groups you know we will see that there's
a person who will have hairdressing
skills uh there's a farmer there's a
person who can teach tell stories you
know they can teach traditional
songs you know at the end of the day
there's just so much like in kba kba is
one of the groups um there's H cooking
skills there's you know people who can
wash clothes there are people who can te
land there are people who can build
houses there are people who have um food
to offer yes so that's a good example
and and so like my understanding is a
you a community is made up of around 20
people yes and how many of these
communities do you have right now we
have 120 groups in Kenya and also Beyond
Uganda
colia yes yeah and just give us a bit of
an indication how have people using this
over the last years like the
transactions you've had and we can talk
a little bit about the offchain and
onchain element as well yeah so in Kenya
they use the ussd wallet which is also
um connected to the web interface um so
each of these users um of the vouchers
have a wallet um and so when they're
doing the trades they normally just end
the vouchers so for instance when
they're doing the rotation of Labor they
the host will accept um these people to
come and work for him build a house at
the end of the day the host will pay
them with the vouchers the next time
they'll go to someone else and the
vouchers will will be paid so there are
going to be several pools and the pools
are going to be interconnected together
uh by um having a market day that is
unique for that is common for all the
groups so that is where the pools meet
and more and more services are exchanged
yeah that's amazing so some of us came
and visited uh the operations in kifi
and we actually use the uh ussd app is
basically for feature phone so you're
basically using the telone network to
send commitment vouchers to each other
and each transaction would trigger an
onchain transaction from a wallet that
is actually connected to the phone
number of that person yeah right and did
I hear correctly there's a million
transactions have happened
1.2 transactions wow wow and how many
people used it so far we have
65,000 um holders and issuers of these
vouchers commitments yeah so this is
like rethinking what what is money
ultimately right money is kind of a
representation of a commitment it's a
bank note You' use money to go back and
get some value from a bank right you
guys have basically used actually
Primitives to recreate like a localized
money system built with commitments and
these polls of a community connects to
many other community polls yes so
there's basically like we're sharing
liquidity but liquidity is not like a
dollar stable coin it is basically
actual commitments people are making
what has been the impact that you've
seen so far in how this is changing
people's lives you talked about houses
being built like yeah what have people
been able to do with this yeah so I'm
going to give you a good example of what
I actually do and how I get to know all
the kinds of impacts on the ground so we
are also borrowing another traditional
practice from the past you know um the
idea of a Cel meeting so every time the
rotation of labor would happen and a
cycle would end the elders would meet
and discuss matters Community like what
are the issues we have like what do we
need to work towards is it a planting
season do we need a water pan you know
so that would um motivate and and also
you know decide like what kind of
activities they'll be meeting to do so
what we do we we now are doing is
identifying like a community
representative also from the community
and this is the person who is also going
to be attending some of the rotation of
Labor associations and recording the
kind of activities made like a house was
built 15 members took one hour or took
two hours you know and then so what you
do the pools also accept uh stable coins
like cod dollar and this is really to
support with uh communication so what
you're doing is like buying some of the
monitoring and evaluation from the from
these stewards from the community so
when we put them into the pool we put in
Prior it's production financing and then
we take the vouchers which are the
commitments or which um the offerings
the monitoring and evaluation Services
once the report is sent end of the month
um we send the vouchers back to the to
the owner you know the monitoring
evaluation Services uh vouchers and then
they are able now to go into the pool
and take some of the cell dollar and
eventually offramp those to Fat so so to
understand the the kind of impact
created we are able to see the
transactions on the dashboard which also
relates to to all the reports sent like
uh these transactions today equals to 10
houses five Farms five roads fixed and
this is from the community members so
also speaking to sustainability of this
uh
project yeah so um we kind of all got
together before this panel
and when I heard and I understood what
this was it was incredible
mindblowing and I wanted to just add
some thoughts as to why this is really
special when I got into crypto you know
one of the first things I read was um
andreas' book and it was talking about
the history of money and we talk about
the batter system now one of the
challenges with the batter system is
this notion of double coincidence of
once so even if I have I don't know
shoes and you you have a shirt if I if
you don't want my shoes we can't
transact so this solution first of all
solves that problem because you you
don't need to want something in real
time it's sort of like this this
commitment the second thing that I
thought was incredibly valuable about
this as well is I talked about this idea
of the lack of credit right and how do
you build sort of unchain reputation and
how do you unlock
capital I think what is incredibly
interesting about like grass economics
and the work that you do as well is that
people who don't have money can actually
get something offered to them on credit
without them having money and putting
anything at risk so we all talk about
def Def and things like that but for you
to get a loan on chain day you need to
have Capital so when we talk about 2.5
billion people that are not yet on chain
and need access to Opportunities how do
you
unlock sort of those opportunities so
this is super interesting in that regard
now if you take this idea two steps
forward and this is why I'm so excited
about what you're doing and I'll round
up quickly but number one is that
because every commitment is on
chain each of the 65,000 people now
actually have unchain reputation that
can be used as a credit score to then
actually give them real Capital into
that
Community right and in the final piece
when I think about it is a lot of
majority of
Africa almost everybody is doing sort of
like
agriculture now people small scale
farmers are farming you know
um goods and things like that that gets
transported to the
cities when the farmers sell you know
let say maze they sell it for $1 when it
gets to the stores in the cities it's
$10 so if you're trying to create wealth
you want to sort of bridge that gap
between the sale at production and the
cost at consumption and how do you bring
that back into the
villages so for me like what you guys
are doing is is is incredible and I
can't wait to build and co-create
together I think it's it's amazing yeah
it's amazing like there's just so many
ways there's so many ways to use the
commitments um even for big businesses
like you know they create their own
vouches to act as loyalty points uh and
this is also a call for everyone like
it's it's an open you know um it's for
everyone like there's so many ways to
use the vouchers like even Market you
know like I mentioned loyalty points
yeah to make your to keep your business
going and to keep your clients coming
yeah and um so you know a lot of what
you're building is not just technology
you're leveraging existing social
infrastructures and trust
infrastructures and can you give us a
bit of more context of where does that
come from like what are other patterns
like Chamas that you've seen where
basically social trust is the foundation
for um how we relate and interact with
each other even
economically so um first of all before
press was really um built when
commitments were made commitments were
accepted and commitments were fulfilled
so nothing recreated same same so
they're just doing exactly what they
were doing then and really making sure
that now at least now the the the
commitments have value you know the the
can be able to know like how much of my
commitments are worth yours
yeah and do we need the blockchain for
that the blockchain for that I mean
that's that's one question someone might
ask like like why are we building with
crypto on this in your opinion uh for
visibility number one it's also builds
trust because you're able to see like
how many of these are here and also you
know the confidence that I know I can
get this even without money even the
people who don't have money at that
moment they are sure that they will get
what they they have you know cuz it's on
blockchain yeah and actually no I was
just going to actually add to that and I
think if you even look at like how big
savings groups so they're called Saku in
Kenya are right now they're holding tens
of millions of dollars to the point
where the government had to regulate
them and I think those kind of
communities is what just tells you like
people have been enabling and like
coming together to organize themselves
to build their own kind of like local
bank and and in most cases crypto is not
really required but what crypto does is
right now if you go to asako and ask
them how much can I borrow on what is my
collateral uh SOS mostly work also on a
reputational basis so you have to have a
garant all of those things are
incredibly manual which makes SOS a
painful process even while they have aom
that would rival uh most micr Finance
Banks and tier 3 tier 2 banks in a
country right uh bringing it on chain is
literally the you know the secret to now
helping them to unboard so many more
people much faster and you know you're
not trying to replace their processes
and like their um the way they do things
and there are hundreds and thousands of
these circles in Kenya alone in Kenya so
these are basically small like
Cooperative Society Banks of made of 10
to 20 30 people right it's crazy and and
I think you know coming back to why
blockchain perspective it would be
really hard to have a 100 different
commitment pools connected and actually
sharing um like commitment polls with
each other and I think that would not
happen on paper and like doing this on
chain and also go ahead sorry BEC really
easy yeah yeah and and and doing this on
chain and having also a commitment poll
with a pair of Fiat pull like with
stable coin or something like that for
people to exit if they want to I I think
this I guess like the the the I think
the most interesting part of this
conversation for me is that we can do
both it's not about like hey Africa is
crude so then maybe let's dollarize the
whole continent stable coins for
everyone that's that's helping in
integrating us with the world but that's
not the only solution I think what
you're doing is actually making a level
of localization that would be really
hard to do on paper or with web 2 like
making that scalable but in still
maintaining the small element of it I
think it's super
powerful I think we should jump into
questions from you
all
Mark um while we wait for the questions
to come up any uh last Reflections from
you guys yes I think
um the part that we've not spoken about
about
is this idea of like open finance and
that as a builder I can contribute to
her
ecosystem without even having to talk to
her because these commitments and these
individuals are on chain and that is
actually the truest form of
innovation um
so yeah it's just it's just amazing to
kind of see this future where we have
like open financial services that just
connects people businesses from across
the
world we have a number of questions here
uh I want to ask uh briefly is PDP
trading a big thing in
Africa is
yes uh so I was uh one of the earliest
uh the first African hire for binance in
Africa and sort of worked on a number of
things including
b2p um and also built probably the
largest um synthetic African stable coin
um that was doing about 700 million a
week uh peerto peer so the answer is yes
nice um what western Builders trying to
provide crypto services in Africa do not
understand
yeah yeah maybe I can take that I think
the the thing I've seen the most uh
which I I always help my friends
especially if they're coming from like
you know some geography or you know like
let's say the US Europe UK Asia New
Zealand Australia wherever the thing
they don't understand is fragmentation
problem is not on a financial level only
it's also on a cultural level uh within
a country like even Kenya um there's the
Muslim Community that needs Sharia
compliant banking so like a lot of
crypto investing is like completely you
know removed from them like they
wouldn't be able to invest in most
tokens wouldn't be able to invest in
crypto unless it was Sharia compliance
um there's other nuances to say that
like um as y said you know more than you
know 2.5 billion people living under 50
cents a day um I think the banking the
unbanked pitch never you know goes well
with me because these books don't need
to be unbanked they've already been
unbanked they're using mobile money
their their bank account is just an
accessory for them uh understanding that
is very crucial because then you
actually know how to distill a solution
to them and in some cases a solution to
them could be serving who who they're
served by so going to the supermarket
going to the grocery store going to the
oil company going to the um retail chain
uh and helping them make their processes
more efficient because those costs go
down and down back to the actual uh
people within like a particular Market
those nuances are always ignored um and
you know never go well because when you
think oh 1.4 billion people in Africa
you know uh majority population under 25
all of those stats are very exciting
you're like I'm going to go ahead and
launch it and everyone will be amazed
and like they'll use what I'm I'm I'm
I'm building and like you know giving to
them uh but I said this on a video and
I'll say it again it's like uh Africa
needs water not vitamins we're in the
we're in the point where we need
necessity tools uh and most people need
necessity tools they don't need nice to
haves um when you come with that
perspective you will quickly distill uh
SAS tool that helps you with time
management or you know some kind of like
productivity
tracker um that that's really not what
the uh folks are looking for at this
time but if we do the lowlevel uh the
the high the lowlevel plumbing stuff
then you open up uh the flow for those
kind of use cases that's kind of like
what I think Western Builders you know
might not quite understand we have we
have like a lot of questions so I want
to be very short with my answer in terms
of what you can do as a builder thinking
about the the African continent the best
thing you can do is get on a plane and
go to one of the Cities you would learn
way more than anything I would say on
the yeah and I have two two quick takes
on that one is Empire Building doesn't
work uh if you're basically saying hey
we're just going to create the alipe
that's going to eat everything across
all of Africa and be the only thing good
luck trying to execute on that I would
love to meet you and wish you all the
success um but it's basically a lot of
pieces tackling different problems and
the second bit it's a bit of a spicy
take is that um there's actually profit
in Africa I'm sorry guys I know this is
a weird term and frame for a lot of us
building in crypto but we tend to build
with a lot of sort of assumed Visions
for the future but there's a positive
feedback loop by adding value to real
people is they're willing to pay for it
so a lot of tools that we see like this
across Africa actually are profitable
they're building actual businesses that
can last a long period of time and
that's not a bad thing and that's a
great thing um what evm chams are most
widely used in Africa and if there's a
dominant one why do you think that chain
gain more adoption and if non evm chain
then uh like chains that are getting
what are the non evm chains that are
gaining adoption um jamb you guys are on
Cell right can you tell us a little bit
of if you understand why you guys chose
to work with cell
specifically
yeah talk
about it's been a journey for Grassroots
economics like we started with paper
vouchers and of course we went to
digital we've tried out with different
blockchains and cell obviously became um
better um because at least you know we
have a validator now that uh people can
stti into yeah yeah because you you guys
are running a operating a valid a cell
of validator all right so that's a very
interesting model you're you're
contributing to its success but also
using the chain yeah and what about you
guys yeah I was going to say like um you
know ethereum is definitely like a
primary but like one of the chains
people don't actually think about is
like Tron Tron is very big in Africa uh
and it's big for a couple of reasons but
one of the core primary ones is the
exchange that was doing the most on the
continent uh a couple of years ago is
still quite big now was binance uh there
was a time where like the two primary
chains they had was like a theum and
Tron uh we tend to think that people are
like oh there's this huge evm ecosystem
I'll jump to the next thing but we're
actually very simplistic beings all of
us humans like where the first thing
that I used is something that I'm
comfortable with for whatever reason and
it's just maybe because it was like the
first thing that I experienced so Tron
is massive in Africa and then non evm
chains like um even even outside of the
their ecosystem Stellar is a huge chain
that uh we use at Honey con and Pier um
but we've intentionally made made
ourselves evm compatible cuz we're
seeing all of these different exciting
like you know new developments like uh
like world for example you know creating
their own blockchain which is evm
compatible that's very intentional
because like for them they want to own
their ecosystem own their users and
that's kind of like the only way to do
it um but I think for me like ethereum
Tron Stellar cell would be the top
chains that are most widely used in
Africa uh um are these questions going
to be available afterwards because these
are like really really great questions
and I wish I wish I
could answer like all of them um but I
think we've kind of talked about the evm
evm stuff and we have just two minutes
um and I think maybe the last question
is a good way to end the panel which is
just like what crypto-based products do
we reach exed in Africa um I'm generally
interested in anything that actually
allows an unchain economy to thrive um
and the most popular digital economic
infrastructure in the world that is at
what I call population scale that is
used by a billion people is the India
stack but the India stack is very
similar to impesa impesa was mobile
money owned by a particular corporation
the India stack is also technology that
is owned by the government right usdc or
USD or stable coins is digital money
that is on the blockchain and so the
India stack and ideas across identity
digital locker and like like moving that
and putting that on chain as well I
think is the next sort of big like
really big meta and people across the
global majority are building this
building blocks and they're going to be
composable so that that stream is
actually when when people talk about
real world ethereum that's kind of like
what I think think you know the India
stack on chain quickly you guys what
other crypto-based projects you wish
existed uh for me like uh one one of one
of the ones that's like been you know
going across my mind for a long time
is so uh RPC layers that make crypto
feel less scary for people now I say
that to to mean uh imagine telling your
grandma that no you should have sent it
to this ethereum address now the crypto
is gone you send it to a random one
onchain right right she will basically
wonder what are you even talking about I
tried to send you money uh can't you
just call them and they'll reverse it
now I don't have italic number but I
don't think anyone in the etherum
foundation can help if you send crypto
to the wrong address right um but that
RPC layer is interesting to me oh
because uh like we need to build more SC
real around it yeah jamb is anas for
like uh for like um the
addresses well no like even withouts I
think that RPC lay is like helpful so
like you can reverse you can like
authorize transactions that kind well
thank you all so much for the session
here and for listening to us I hope you
found I hope you found it valuable and
if you want to take this relationship to
the next level you're very welcome to
visit at the continent and spend time in
many of these communities thank
Youk
you big thank you to all the panelists
that was awesome and have a lovely
afternoon
[Music]